we hope to enjoy with our friends and
partners from January and from the
outset we were totally clear that we
wanted nothing more complicated than a
Canada style relationship based on
friendship and free trade to judge by
the latest EU Summit in Brussels that
won't work for our EU Partners they want
the continued ability to control our
legislative Freedom our Fisheries in a
way that is completely unacceptable to
an independent country and since we have
only 10 weeks until the end of the
transition period on January the 1 I
have to make a judgment about the likely
outcome and to get us already ready and
given that they have refused to
negotiate seriously for much of the last
few months and given that this Summit
appears explicitly to rule out a Canada
style deal I've concluded that we should
get ready for January the 1st with
arrang ments that are more like
Australia's based on simple principles
of global free trade and we can do it
because we always knew that there would
be change on January the 1st whatever
type of relationship we had and so now
is the time for our businesses to get
ready and for our holers to get ready
for travelers to get ready and of course
we're willing to discuss the
practicalities with our friends where a
lot of progress has already been made uh
by the way on such issues as Social
Security and Aviation nuclear
cooperation and so
on but for whatever reason it's clear
from the summit that after 45 years of
membership they are not willing unless
there's some fundamental change of
approach to offer this country the same
terms as Canada and so with High hearts
and with complete confidence we will
prepare to embrace the alternative and
we will prosper mightily as an
independent free trading Nation
controlling our own borders our
fisheries and setting our own laws and
in the meantime the government will of
course be focusing on tackling coid and
building back better so that 2021 is a
year of recovery and renewal thank you
very much just a couple of questions now
for you prime minister you said that
you'd walk away from talks with the EU
about a trade deal if there wasn't
significant progress by now it doesn't
sound as though that is what you're
doing can you just clarify why you're
not walking away well I as far as I can
see there they've abandoned the idea of
a of a free trade deal there doesn't
seem to be uh any progress coming from
from Brussels so what we're saying to
them is only you know come here come to
us if if there's some fundamental change
of approach otherwise we're more than
happy to talk about you know the
practicalities that I described the
Social Security issues Road hoage and
and so on but and unless as a
fundamental change of approach we we're
going to go for the Australia solution
and we should do it with great
confidence as I said High hearts
confidence because we can do it there
was always going to be change on January
the 1st uh but it's becoming clear that
the the EU don't want to do the type of
Canada deal that uh you know we
originally asked for and it it does seem
curious that uh after 45 years of of
membership they can offer our membership
they can offer Canada terms they won't
offer us but you're saying they've got
to come to you with some fresh ideas
about negotiations are you saying you
are walking away or you're not walking
away well if there's a fundamental
change of approach of course we're
always willing to listen but um didn't
seem particularly encouraging from uh
The Summit in Brussels um yesterday and
today on Co 19 are you willing to impose
restrictions on places like greater
Manchester without the buying of local
leaders I much rather that we were able
to do things with the help uh support
the leadership of of local authorities
and I look I pay tribute to to Liverpool
City region to Lancashire that uh uh
came and on board today with the teering
uh system uh in London uh you've seen
the mayor uh come on board as well and
that's very very important because uh
clearly you know if you're going to
enforce these measures if you're going
to do a local testing and and tracing if
you're going to get a local buyin and
compliance and local leadership is is
crucial and we want to work with local
leaders but you know I am I have to say
Paul concerned about what's happening in
Manchester where clearly the the levels
of of infection are rising uh steeply
the levels of hospitalization are rising
steeply and we do need to see action and
you know you say I I'd much rather not
imp postings I'd much rather that we
were able to to work out uh work out
something together with local
authorities with the mayor in Manchester
but it's up to to local leaders to show
the kind of leadership that we've seen
in Liverpool in Lancashire and in London
lastly on this you say it's up to local
leaders but you could break the
stalemate by offering them the money
that they want which is similar to the
financial assistance during the first
national lockdown why don't you think
that's a reasonable request well other
as I say other local leaders have have
come forward uh and and and joined in
the tiering system shown the kind of
leadership that uh I think is is
necessary and this is this is about
saving lives this is about uh us joining
together locally and nationally to uh
get the r down to make uh these Regional
restrictions this tearing system work
and and to save lives and I think uh you
know everybody in uh in Greater
Manchester and all the are which are
still uh finding it difficult should
should think about it okay